[Music]
susan's in gainesville florida hi susan
how are you
hi dave
i'm i'm in a quandary
i've been following you for years um
two years from paying off my house
and um recently i've been told that
i may need to have a liver transplant
and
in doing the research
my my insurance will
pay for for a portion of it
up to my
yearly deductible
um
or my yearly my yearly out of pocket
and um
but then
there are
drugs after
after the liver
transplant that you end up taking for
the rest in your life at
300 a month
and um
i'm single and
i'm 60 years old and i only have 150
in my 401k and
i don't know
what to do the
research is telling me
it's a lifetime commitment of like 500
000
um
you know i just i can't i can't even
imagine
how i'm going to
how i'm going to pay that off well
there's
so there's so many things here to be
afraid of isn't there
yeah i mean when you just say liver
transplant i go whoa you know
and then when you say 500 000 i go whoa
double whoa yeah there's a lot going on
i i can imagine you're scared what do
you make a year
well i work from home uh i work for a
company out of state um as a technical
writer so
um
i think i paid uh
85 in taxes this year
on
good and the good news is that
you know
that doesn't require a lot of physical
exertion
and so after you're in recovery you'll
be able to resume work fairly quick
right uh yeah they're telling me about
three to six months yeah that's pretty
and i and my company
provides the short-term
uh disability where i'll make um
two-thirds during
during
the time i'm out
um
uh for the years that i've been
my heart just goes out to you i'm so
sorry for what you're going through i
just i can hear the pain in your voice
christina yeah
um well it's keeping me up at night it's
i mean i i just
you know i
i've i've been a ramsey for a long time
i've even i've even um
facilitated at my church uh on two
different occasions and
i've never heard
heard you talk about this and so
here's the here's the here's the truth
of the situation
sometimes uh for me anyway i don't know
if this works for you
but sometimes once i understand i'm
doing something
period
then the fear starts to go away
because here's the deal medically this
is scary
but you're doing it you don't have a
choice
right
well
not if i want to live well there you go
that's what i mean we're doing it so
game on right uh scary scary but uh
obligation yeah scary but straight up
you know dying is not an option here
we're gonna not when we have other
options on the table
and so game on you know let's do it uh
and it is scary but you're just
embracing the
the the facts of the situation and
you're going all right i really can't
i'm not really going to worry about this
i've just got to do it now as far as the
300 a month you make 85 000 a year
you're okay
it's not 500 000 and it's not 500 000
out of your pocket
this is a 500 000 total bill the
insurance is going to cover the the vast
majority of you're going to cover your
deductible and your co-pays
and
some other stuff that insurance doesn't
cover that's associated with this but
let's say it's 50 000 bucks
plus 300 a month
and we get to keep susan around
i like the plan let's do it
but i i've already
almost depleted my emergency fund and
our other option is die
no don't think so
well also i do love that you said that
you're doing a lot of research and
you're kind of exploring what's out
there i would encourage you to continue
leaning into that i don't know if you've
looked into any of the
prescription drug programs that kind of
reduce the cost like i know there's a
lot of coupon programs like goodrx then
i know there's some other ones out there
so i would definitely go through and see
if there's any option out there that
will reduce that cost and then i would
connect with some other survivors people
who have been through what you're going
through have seen those bills and been
overwhelmed and somehow got through it i
think they're going to have some of the
best wisdom and insights for you so
here's what's going to happen susan all
right
you're going to have a liver transplant
and you're going to have
a bill that's 300 a month
and five years from now you're going to
be making 85 or 100 000 a year you'll be
65 years old a survivor of a transplant
surgery you're gonna be paying three to
five hundred dollars a month in uh
prescription drugs and you will have
come out of pocket with 50k
and you'll be fine you'll be all right
150 still there you know you're going to
work your way through this you make
enough money to work your way through
this um you can continue to you'll be
able to start adding back to your
retirement again this is not going to
bankrupt you
it doesn't have to not my retirement for
now
i would just sit on it right now you
don't need to write any checks yet
nobody sent you a bill yet
yeah actually i i i as i said i i've
nearly depleted my emergency okay then
go ahead and stop your retirement and
let's pile up cash stop stop retirement
let's pile up cash as fast and as high
as you can how long are you going to be
on this list waiting on a liver do you
think
well i've been told it could be anywhere
from
two weeks to two years yep okay
so game on let's pile up cash
i'm looking at at some
things
um
some organizations that that
help financially
um
to apply well kind of like connect to
standards with their schooling sure
um
yeah here's the thing
i think you're going to have the 50 000
in cash before you need it
because you're gonna put 50 000 cash
real fast together because you stopped
your retirement you stopped everything
and you're piling up cash like crazy
because you're scared
if you weren't scared you wouldn't be
human and i'm not making light of your
situation you called me asking me for
hope and i'm telling you you're gonna be
okay
but it's not false it's not gonna be
easy it's gonna be you got a hard two
three four years ahead of you uh and
then you're you're gonna be okay
financially you're gonna be okay
medically unless something goes wrong
that we haven't discussed on this call
and so i can
standing outside of your fear which you
should have that fear i would be scared
to crapless if it was me
okay i get it i'm with you okay but i'm
standing over here not in the middle of
it looking at your numbers in your life
listening to a lady who's already a
survivor you're already a scrappy woman
aren't you
yeah you've been scrapping a long time
that's just one more fight double up
your fist girl
okay you can do it
you can do it and and i'm not making
light of your situation and i'm not
making light of you having some fear i
hear the fear in your voice i hear
the hopelessness in your voice but my
job is to speak life over you
and it's and it's based in facts not
based in
the hope i'm speaking over you and
christina and i are speaking over is
based in facts not based in
pollyanna positive thinking or something
i can tell you that a woman that makes
85 000 a year that stops her retirement
can pile up 50 grand pretty fast boom i
can tell you the woman makes 85 000 a
year five years from now is gonna be
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
boom i know that a woman making that
kind of money can pay 300 a month in
prescription and be okay boom i can see
the math is gonna be okay
but i'm not the one facing all of it so
it's not as scary for me so my job is to
say hey i love you
i'm afraid with you
but you're gonna be okay
you're gonna get there you call us back
if you need some help honey